[Musique]
déjà fait du surf mademoiselle farmer
non parce que l'eau est un élément qui
m'est fait donc je préfère l'équitation
vous avez fait beaucoup d'équitation et
j'en ai fait comme ça je m'orientais or
je pense que oui c'était j'avais un bon
niveau
j'avais envie de faire une carrière mais
j'avoue j'ai abandonné l'idée à 18 10
mais vous étiez une très très bonne
cavalière veiller très nommé cuillère je
crois non n'exagérons pas et remet vous
êtes en compagnie de laurent boutonnat
parce que laurent boutonnat travaille
beaucoup avec vous c'est lui même qui je
crois vous a incité à faire de la
chanson c'est à dire qu'aux essais on
s'est rencontré et lui et compositeur
donc à une passion pour la musique pour
le cinéma également vont parler et donc
m'a proposé avec notre une autre
personne la première chanson qui était
maman a tort et depuis voilà une
travaillons ensemble
alors comment queue basse que le temps
comme ça d'un coup de l'équitation à la
chanson une bonne étoile au dessus de ma
tête certainement beaucoup de chance et
puis depuis deux ans beaucoup de travail
ou de cheval laurent boutonnat
c'est la voix le physique de mylène
farmer que vous avez séduit ou c'est sur
les deux à la fois oui c'est les deux à
la fois parce que on cherchait quelqu'un
au moment où on avait fait cette chanson
avec un ami qui était maman a tort c'est
une chanson un peu spécial qui se
passait dans un hôpital psychiatrique
d'une petite fille et jour mylène est
arrivée elle était elle était parfaite
quoi parce qu'elle avait l'air un peu
pervers ou pas c'était pas tellement
perverse plutôt psychotique qu'un un peu
embêté quoi
oui très bizarre mais ça a été l tout de
suite quoi même avant de l'entendre
chanter alors vous lui avez écrit
libertines qui est un véritable succès
qui a fait un tabac cet été c'est en
train de faire un tabac
parce qu'on le montre là enfin je me
suis ravi que ça marche
alors c'est un texte c'est un texte qui
est aussi un petit peu pervers ou un peu
ambigu comme en voudra c'est un texte
qui n'est pas ce n'est pas très simple
de m mais curieusement c'est assez drôle
d'entendre c'est curieux que ça marche
enfin je suis ravi que sa mort mais
c'est drôle d'entendre dans la bouche
des enfants chanter je je suis libertine
je suis une cata si ça ne change admise
et c'est à vous amuser mais il n'y a
rien à 13 euros
c'est un fils et un clip un film qui
dure onze minutes c'est pas trés
vendable ça à la télévision pour passer
dans un journal parlait s'est réjoui
c'est dommage mais je pense qu'il y aura
une
une promotion cinématographie c'est à
dire dans les salles de cinéma on attend
c'est en pourparlers
ce serait l'idéal parce qu'ils vous
pensez que ça aide beaucoup à la
promotion d'un disque et la fabrication
d'un clip très très sophistiqués comme
celui là mais moi je veux pas faire de
généralités je pense qu'en ce qui me
concerne le travail qui est fait depuis
deux ans pour moi c'est essentiel
d'avoir ce clip et le clip précédent
parce que c'est un travail c'est un
travail d'image et puis c'est oui c'est
enrichir je crois un personnage déjà et
puis et puis une chanson pour vous les
deux sont indissociables aujourd'hui
pour moi à dissocier have réellement
mais parce que laurent boutonnat parce
que palin mentor tout à l'heure pour moi
c'est surtout un admirable metteur en
scène mais dans toute sa généralité que
ça vous donne le goût de faire du cinéma
je rêve de faire du cinéma là depuis que
je suis tout petit et j'espère en faire
un jour mais tous sa souffrance et très
réfléchies
alors vous justement laurent boutonnat
depuis que vous êtes tout petit et que
vous avez dix ans je crois vous faites
du cinéma et de la musique solutionner
la wii c'est là j'ai fait du piano j'ai
appris la musique et l'harmonie très
jeune et j'ai commencé à faire des films
très jeunes filles à 10 ans comme ça en
super-8 des petits films et c'est
toujours deux choses que j'ai fait j'ai
toujours fait des petits films j'ai fait
la musique de mes petits films offrent
ainsi toujours des activités d activité
que j'ai fait nul ça que vous avez une
formation de classiques de conservatoire
pas de conservatoire mais des cours de
piano j'ai commencé à faire du piano à 5
ans jusqu'à 13 14 ans puis après j'ai
tout envoyé pas la démission de l'école
c'est marrant parce qu'on assiste en ce
moment à une éclosion de deux jeunes
femmes comme vous qui ont des visages
très doux on leur donnerait le bon dieu
sans confession si je puis dire
et puis tissu sur qui je crois est
rentré très libertines là que réside
toute la carte version break c'est un
phénomène d'époque
non mais je pense que c'est
et c'est plus plus intéressant de
travailler parce qu'une chanson c'est
bien mais c'est un peu c'est quelque
chose de très sain mais travailler
autour de sale image et tout ce que ça
comporte
ça c'est passionnant bien et bien
écoutez merci d'être venu antennes 2010
mylène farmer et laurent boutonnat je
rappelle ce titre libertines métier déjà
très très connue doit être dans le top
50 des gens ayant largement ma bible du
français chez pas beaucoup la j'écoute
la radio je sais que top 50 c'est une
référence c'est vrai nous sommes dans le
top 50 ça veut dire que le disque vanves
n'a que l'artiste fonctionnement dans
mes bornes dernier pour vous
[Musique]